vorboten einer supernova direkt in
unserer nachbarschaft oder etwas anderes
noch immer ist nicht endgültig geklärt
was eigentlich mit einem der größten und
hellsten sterne unserer milchstraße los
ist seit oktober 2009 10 verlor beta
gold seine helligkeit und die frage nach
dem warum stellt die wissenschaft
weltweit in den vergangenen monaten vor
große rätsel jetzt liefern
forschungsteams einen neuen möglichen
erklärungsansatz für dieses mysterium
das vorspiel einer supernova klicks um
25 user gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos aktiviert die
glocke und abonniert den kanal nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
seit oktober des vergangenen jahres 2019
bereitet der monster stern beteigeuze
der wissenschaft kopfzerbrechen denn
seitdem verlor der stern an helligkeit
und das nicht zu knapp innerhalb von nur
wenigen wochen hatte beteigeuze im
vergangenen herbst also enorm an
leuchtkraft verloren dass er um rund
zwei drittel dunkler wurde war sogar mit
dem bloßen auge zu erkennen und es
konnten weitere veränderungen des roten
überriesen es offenbart werden denn auch
seine temperatur hatte sich verändert
150 kelvin weniger als während seines
händigkeit maximums wurden
beispielsweise anfang diesen jahres 2020
gemessen
mögliche erklärungsansätze für diese
mysteriöse beobachtung stehen seitdem im
raum anfangs gegen manche fachleute noch
davon aus dass die variablen licht
zyklen des sterns dahinter stecken
könnten
peter gold sind nämlich ändert
regelmäßig seine helligkeit und
möglicherweise so dachte man damals
könnte der helligkeitsverlust mit einem
minimum der beiden licht zyklen erklärt
werden doch dazu war die verdunklung
doch etwas zu krass dazu heißt es auf
der webseite der max-planck-gesellschaft
rote riesensterne wie beteigeuze
unterliegen häufigen
helligkeitsschwankungen der markante
abfall der leuchtkraft von peter golde
auf etwa 40 prozent seines normalwerts
zwischen oktober 2010 und april 2020 kam
für die astronomen jedoch überraschend
ein riesiges rätsel also für die
wissenschaft und viele fragen sind offen
handelt sich bei dem veränderung etwa um
die vorzeichen einer gewaltigen
supernova die kurz bevorsteht oder sind
des stern flecken oder gar große
staubwolken die die
unregelmäßige verteilung der dunklen
ställen verursacht fragen über fragen
doch nun gibt es einige neue
erklärungsansätze aus der wissenschaft
und genau darum geht es in diesem video
übrigens alle beobachtungen die wir
derzeit zudem monster stern beteigeuze
machen zeigen uns was um das jahr 1300
wirklich mit dem stern passiert ist wenn
peter gosse ist rund 700 lichtjahre von
uns entfernt also so lange braucht das
licht bis es unsere erde erreicht was
wir bisher sicher über betreut zu wissen
er gehört zu den sechs bis sieben
hellsten sternen am himmel
es handelt sich um den schulter stern
des orion ein roter über riese und er
macht dieser bezeichnung wirklich alle
ehre
wenn dieser stern hat den tausendfachen
durchmesser der sonne ein raumschiff
wäre rund zehn jahre unterwegs um den
stern zu umrunden
doch nicht nur das außerdem hat peter
kreuzer auch eine etwa 10.000 mal
größere leuchtkraft als die sonne
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben bereits klar gemacht dass seine
supernova zu einem gigantischen
naturspektakel führen würde
das ist das typische ende eines
riesensterns wie beteigeuze millionen
jahre lang bekommen sie energie dadurch
dass atomkerne verschmelzen kernfusion
dort irgendwann ist der brennstoff
verbraucht damit geht der stern ins
finale er kollabiert und verwandelt sich
in eine supernova
dabei wird fast seine gesamte gashülle
ins weltall herausgeschleudert bei
dieser explosion würde peter kreuz so
viel energie freisetzen wie achtung
unsere sonne
während ihrer gesamten lebensdauer der
grund dafür im kosmischen dimensionen
gesehen ist uns beteigeuze mit einer
entfernung von rund 700 lichtjahre sehr
nah der über riese würde bei einer
supernova sogar tagsüber von uns am
himmel zu sehen sein und nach zeller
strahlen als der vollmond eine echte
premiere für die menschheit die selbst
unsere ältesten vorfahren auf der erde
so wahrscheinlich noch nie zu gesicht
bekommen haben
die auswertung historischer
überlieferung legt tatsächlich nahe dass
solche supernovae bislang nie in einer
solch kurzen distanz zur erde
stattgefunden haben doch wie
wahrscheinlich ist eine zeitnahe
supernova wirklich dazu schreibt jetzt
ein internationales forschungsteam in
einer aktuellen studie
die chance dass dieser stern irgendwann
demnächst super nova wird ist ziemlich
gering die us astronomen andrea dupree
war an der analyse
heilig und betont wie super spannend
dieses forschungsfeld ist denn solche
daten von den wochen und tagen direkt
vor einer explosion seien bislang noch
nie aufgenommen worden
keiner weiß was an stern direkt vor
seiner super nova tut man es noch nie
beobachtet hat bislang hat man also nur
erkenntnisse dazu wie die sterne einige
jahre vor solch einem ereignis
ausgesehen haben zusammen mit ihren
kolleginnen kollegen hat die us
astronomen andrea die daten des
weltraumteleskops hubble ausgewertet und
neue erkenntnisse gewonnen
bis dato galten die ergebnisse einer
studie des max-planck-instituts für
astronomie in heidelberg als plausibel
in deren studie vom ende juni 2020
machen die forschung gigantische stern
flecken für den jüngsten helligkeits
einbruch des roten riesenstern
verantwortlich ihre analyse zufolge
könnten temperaturschwankungen der
photosphäre also der leuchtenden stern
oberfläche für die helligkeit
veränderung von beteigeuze geführt haben
dazu heißt es auf der webseite
die plausibelste quelle für solche
temperaturänderungen sind gigantische
kühle sterne flecken ähnlich wie
sonnenflecken die jedoch 50 bis 70
prozent der sternoberfläche bedecken für
ihre studie hatten die forscher neue und
archivierte daten des atacama pathfinder
experiment apex und des james clerk
maxwell teleskop die cmt ausgewertet
diese teleskope werden schon seit
längerer zeit in der astronomie genutzt
um interstellaren staub genauer zu
analysieren konkret messen sie strahlung
aus dem spektralbereich der sub
millimeterwellen deren wellenlänge
tausendmal größer ist als dieses
sichtbaren lichts und die ergebnisse
waren selbst für die fachleute eine
überraschung dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam was uns überrascht
beteigeuze wurde auch im bereich der
submillimeter wählen um 20 punkte
den bisherigen erkenntnissen der us army
konnte dieses ergebnis allerdings nicht
mit der anwesenheit von staub in
verbindung gebracht werden das zeigten
dann auch weitere berechnungen der
forschungsgruppe demnach muss der stern
selbst für die veränderung der
helligkeit verantwortlich sein so diese
studie dazu heißt es auf der webseite
der max-planck-gesellschaft
physikalische gesetze besagen dass die
leuchtkraft eines sterns von seinem
durchmesser und besonders stark von
seiner oberflächen tempo
natur abhängt verringert sich nur die
größe des sterns sinkt die helligkeit in
allen wellenlängen gleichstark
temperaturänderungen beeinflussen die
abstrahlung entlang des
elektromagnetischen spektrums jedoch
unterschiedlich die gemessene
verdunklung im sichtbaren licht und in
den sub millimeterwellen ist nach
ansicht der wissenschaftler daher ein
beleg für eine verringerung der
mittleren oberflächentemperatur von
beteigeuze die sie auf 200k oder 200
grad celsius beziffern konkret macht
diese studie also riesige stern flecken
für die verdunklung von beteigeuze
verantwortlich bisher war bereits
bekannt dass diese auf riesensterne
vorkommen viel mehr weiß man allerdings
nicht dazu sagt peter ski club von der
europäischen südsternwarte eso
entsprechende hochauflösenden bilder von
beteigeuze vom dezember 2009 10 zeigen
bereiche mit unterschiedlicher
helligkeit zusammen mit unserem ergebnis
ist dies ein klarer hinweis auf riesige
stern flecken die zwischen 50 und 70
prozent der sichtbaren oberfläche
bedecken und eine niedrige temperatur
als die hellere photosphäre aufweisen
doch auch schon diese deutsche
forschungsgruppe hatte es für möglich
gehalten dass licht absorbierende staub
für die starke verdunklung gesorgt haben
könnte zumindest hatten die fachleute
das nicht völlig ausgeschlossen doch
ihre analyse der strahlung aus dem
spektralbereich der terahertz strahlung
sprach wie gesagt er dagegen anders
allerdings neue beobachtungen des
hubble-weltraumteleskops diese rücken
nun doch wieder ansammlungen von staub
in den fokus so ist wissenschaft seit
januar diesen jahres 2020 hatte das
forschungsteam um die astronomen andrea
dupri peter golze mit dem uv
spektrografen von hubble genauer im
blick diese daten zeigen ob und auf
welche art und weise sich material von
der oberfläche des monster sterns in die
atmosphäre bewegt hat und tatsächlich
die forschenden konnten so herausfinden
dass es einen heftigen plasma ausbruch
gegeben haben muss dabei sind
gigantische mengen an material mit mehr
als 30.000 kilometern pro stunde ins all
geschleudert worden
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam die uv
beobachtungen zeigen klar eine helle
heiß und innig
struktur die von september bis november
2009 10 in der oberen photosphäre und
unteren kroos fähre des sterns erscheint
die uv linien profile zeigen zudem die
passage einer nach außen gerichteten
druckwelle durch die sterne atmosphäre
die aktuelle studie des us
forschungsteams offenbart vor allem im
südosten des sterns eine heiße und
dichte region die sich nach außen bewegt
laut der expertin experten könnte das
material in diesem bereich zwei bis vier
mal so hell wie der restliche stern
gewesen sein für die fachwelt an sich
kein ungewöhnlicher vorgang der beta
kreuze gehört zu den roten riesen und
diese verlieren immer mal wieder
material bedingt wird dies durch den
prozess im sternen inneren hier finden
konvektion strömung stadt die das
sternen materie aus dem inneren an die
oberfläche bringen wo es aus
geschleudert wird doch das us
forschungsteam hat zudem herausgefunden
dass sich der riesenstern zu diesem
zeitpunkt in einer expandierenden phase
befunden haben muss zur erklärung
mitteilte durchlebt zyklen der
ausdehnung und des zusammenziehen ist
die jeweils etwa 400 tage dauern
da der plasma ausbruch aber mit einer
phase der ausdehnung und starker
konvektion zusammenhielt wurde dieser
wohl enorm verstärkt unter anderen
bedingungen wäre der ausbruch des
plasmas möglicherweise zwei bis drei mal
schwächer ausgefallen so die us
fachleute in ihrer aktuellen studie im
klartext gesprochen heißt das also dass
der monster stern super heißes plasma
von seiner oberfläche ausgestoßen hat
und sich dieses material dann in den
äußeren und kälteren schichten abgekühlt
hat und jetzt kommt das plasma ist
kondensiert und zwar zu einer gewaltigen
staubwolke die den riesenstern verhüllte
die staubwolke hat sich in der
sichtlinie zwischen dem stern und der
erde bewegt und hat somit unsere sicht
auf peter kreuze verdeckt somit erklärt
das forschungsteam die abdunklung von
beteigeuze seit dezember 2019 also mit
einem gigantischen plasma ausbruch seien
april 2020 kehrt der riesenstern stück
für stück wieder zu seiner normalen
helligkeit zurück doch das os
forschungsteam kann und will nicht
ausschließen dass es noch einmal zu
einer erneuten abdunklung kommen könnte
ab ende des monats august 2020 sind
weitere beobachtungen mit dem
hubble-teleskop geplant und auch das
nasa sonnenobservatorium stereo hat den
monster sternen
hier möglich obwohl peter golde derzeit
fast hinter der sonne steht
möglicherweise ist damit also endlich
das rätsel und beteigeuze gelöst die
staubwolke ist dem aktuellen wissenstand
nach jedenfalls die wahrscheinlichste
ursache für die mysteriöse verdunklung
riesenstern beteigeuze neue aktivität
rote überriesen verhält sich merkwürdige
es gibt also noch mehr neuigkeiten
wahrscheinlich wird das was
prognostiziert worden ist für jetzt den
august realität also dieses video
anklicken anschauen und egis kosmos
abonnieren sehr cooler kanal bis dann
bleibt dran